Zehn Kilometer lang und 350 Meter hoch - wow!
Das ist wirklich enormer Hohlraum, den ein
internationales Forschungsteam da unter einem
der größten Antarktis-Gletscher aufgespürt
hat.
Die Kaverne war wohl ursprünglich mal mit
14 Milliarden Tonnen Eis gefüllt.
Und das Tauen geht weiter.
Alleine das Abschmelzen des Thwaites-Gletschers
könnte den weltweiten Meeresspiegel um sage
und schreibe 65 Zentimeter anheben.
Und nicht nur das: Er fungiert als eine Art
“Stöpsel” und verhindert damit eine unbeschreibliche
Katastrophe.
Doch das Drama nimmt seinen Lauf… Was genau
hat es mit dem gigantischen Hohlraum unter
dem Eis auf sich und wie katastrophal ist
das Abschmelzen des Gletschers wirklich?!
Die Antworten dazu bekommt ihr jetzt bei Clixoom
Science & Fiction; hier gibt es täglich spannende
Science-Videos; herzlich willkommen!
Es
geht um den Thwaites-Gletscher in der westlichen
Antarktis, der etwa so groß ist wie der US-Bundesstaat
Florida.
Schon jetzt ist das Tauen dieses Gletschers
für etwa vier Prozent des globalen Meeresspiegelanstieges
verantwortlich.
Und das Drama hat wohl gerade erst begonnen,
denn der jetzt neu aufgespürte gewaltige
Hohlraum unterhalb des Schelfeises sorgt für
große Beunruhigung.
Die Größe dieser Höhle ist kaum zu beschreiben:
Sie ist etwa so hoch wie der Eiffelturm und
ihre Grundfläche entspricht der halben Fläche
des Chiemsees.
Und nicht nur das: Dieser gigantische Hohlraum
enthielt wohl mal etwa 14 Milliarden Tonnen
Eis.
Doch der Großteil davon ist alleine in den
vergangenen drei Jahren geschmolzen.
Schon seit längerer Zeit haben Fachleute
diesen Gletscher und die Region drumherum
besonders kritisch im Blick.
Denn klar ist, dass hier besonders viel Eis
verloren geht.
Doch die jetzt ausgewerteten Radaraufnahmen
überraschten die Forschungsteams selbst.
Denn mit einem extrem-großen Hohlraum, der
in solch beunruhigendem Ausmaß wächst, hatten
die Fachleute nicht gerechnet.
Eine Erklärung gibt es aber schon.
Wärmeres Meerwasser dringt am Endbereich
des Gletschers zum Eis vor und sorgt dafür,
das es von unten abschmilzt.
Und das nicht ohne Folgen.
Die Entstehung eines solchen Hohlraumes beeinflusst
dann auch die weitere Zukunft des Gletschers.
Dazu der NASA-Forscher Pietro Milillo: “Da
mehr Wärme und Wasser unter den Gletscher
gelangen, schmilzt er schneller”.
Die Analyse zeigt Erschreckendes: Denn das
Schelfeis, das auf dem Wasser im vorderen
Bereich der Höhle liegt, schmilzt schneller
als es Modelle vorhersagen.
Zudem schmilzt es schneller als das Eis, das
an jedem anderen Ort in der Antarktis bislang
vermessen wurde.
Warmes, salziges Wasser unterspült den Gletscherteil
und Eismassen vom Landesinneren rutschen nach.
Wenn der Thwaites-Gletscher komplett abschmilzt,
würde dies Schätzungen zufolge einen Anstieg
des Meeresspiegels um 65 Zentimeter bedeuten.
Doch als wäre das nicht katastrophal genug,
wird es bei diesem Szenario wohl nicht bleiben.
Denn der Thwaites-Gletscher hat zusammen mit
seinem “Nachbarn”, dem Pine-Island--Gletscher,
eine unfassbar wichtige Funktion für die
West-Antarktis.
Denn beide stabilisieren weitere Gletscher
und bilden quasi eine Art “Stöpsel”,
der die Eismassen daran hindert, in den Ozean
dahinter zu gelangen.
Passiert dies doch, würde dies laut NASA
einen Anstieg des Meeresspiegels von 2,4 Metern
bedeuten.
Manche Experten und Expertinnen gehen sogar
von einem Anstieg von 3,5 Metern aus.
Schon in einem Zeitraum von hundert Jahren
könnte dieser Prozess demnach ablaufen.
WTF!
Nun stehen dringend weitere Untersuchungen
an, damit wir die Prozesse an den Gletschern
besser verstehen können.
Dazu Eric Rignot von der University of California:
“Um die Auswirkung dieses Gletschers auf
den Meeresspiegelanstieg in den kommenden
Jahrzehnten vorherzusagen, muss man verstehen,
wie das Meer ihn abschmilzt”.
Die aktuelle Untersuchung legt jedoch nahe,
dass die Wechselwirkungen von Gletschern und
Polarmeer deutlich komplexer sind als bisher
gedacht.
Denn bislang ging man davon aus, dass solche
riesigen Kavernen unter den Gletschern eher
statisch sind und eben nicht so rasant wachsend.
Doch schon jetzt steht jedenfalls fest: Schuld
am steigenden Meeresspiegel ist der Klimawandel.
Und er wird nicht nur den Menschen in entfernten
Regionen wie Indonesien, Ägypten oder Thailand
das Zuhause nehmen.
Auch wir in Deutschland, der Niederlande und
Belgien werden betroffen sein.
Und schon jetzt passiert in Teilen der Welt
der reinste Horror: Durch den Anstieg des
Meeresspiegels sind im Pazifik schon jetzt
mindestens acht ganze Insel verschwunden - für
immer.
Betroffen sind Inseln der Salomonen, ein Inselstaat
in der Südsee und auch Mikronesien, ein Inselstaat
im westlichen Pazifischen Ozean.
In beiden Regionen liegt der Anstieg des Meeresspiegels
weit über dem Durchschnitt: Dort wurde nämlich
sogar ein jährlicher Anstieg von 1,2 Zentimetern
gemessen.
Abgesehen davon, dass ihre Heimatinseln eine
große historische Bedeutung für ihre Bewohner
haben, sind die Menschen dort gezwungen, alles
aufzugeben!
Auch Orte, an denen wir gerne Urlaub machen
sind dabei: Zum Beispiel die Dominikanische
Republik, Kuba, die Seychellen oder die Fidschi
Inseln.
Es gibt Studien, die prognostizieren, das
im Jahr 2100 ein Fünftel der Weltbevölkerung
Klimaflüchtlinge sind.
Also mehr als eine Milliarde Menschen, werden
nach Europa und alle anderen höher gelegenen
Gebiete kommen.
Überflutete Küstenregionen sorgen diesem
Szenario nach für eine Massenflucht ins Landesinnere,
in dem dann nutzbare Flächen viel zu knapp
werden.
Die Nahrungsmittelproduktion wird dann extrem
schwierig.
Wir hier in Deutschland müssen einen Großteil
der niederländischen Bevölkerung aufnehmen.
Schon jetzt kommt das Land dem immer schneller
steigenden Meeresspiegel nicht mehr hinterher.
Und durch die weggeschmolzenen Eismassen in
Arktis verdunstet dort immer mehr Wasser,
was zu den starken Regenfällen in den letzten
Jahren geführt hat.
Die Folge sind höhere Pegel des Rheins, der
von der Landseite zeitweise ungeheure Wassermassen
in die Niederlande bringt.
Der Klimawandel ist in vollem Gange und das
viel schneller als gedacht.
Klimawandel: War es der Mensch?
Brandneues Video bei Raumzeit - Vlog der Zukunft:
Unbedingt draufklicken, anschauen und abonnieren!
Bis dann, bleibt dran!